conscious officer news in Puget advances
recently seen purchase television remote
villages popular web at Minnesota so the
premise of a potassium Mucha the MEMS
are teaching
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- energy
what makes this incident so significant
you know that even so
Hostel are going like me there's no one
even else yeah to be honest yeah because
I really wanted to do this project
because you see it's rather is something
really really big elevation is that the
Quran speaks very harshly of it you know
the people are slander against don't
believe in men I believe in women they
punish me so severely as well so it's
not the place the people in society and
people just do it like that like it's
nothing but they don't understand the
damage it causes and one of those
damages is like the sister you know that
has committed suicide maybe it's only
herpes but many people have heard
stories in Canada you know I've heard
stories of sisters saying my once my
brother dragged me into the car beat the
crap out because right because somebody
called went and said oh yo sista did
they send that no proof no evidence he
said she said so this is something that
you need to learn from enough for you
know what if it needs us the boat to
France together as a team we have to go
you know it's so important I even
brother Imran might be catching a plane
to come help us with
okay when you release the post a few
weeks ago yeah she's passed away now you
know the consequences of slander but my
main objective my main objective is that
but I'll only obviously want to build
solidarity sister from looking at
building maybe a couple of water wells
and some olive trees in Gaza so you know
inshaallah so the sisters could benefit
from the hereafter Dubey I'm trying to
say so that's one of my objects if this
were we just don't want to put this we
don't want to just brush this under the
carpet and you know everybody forget it
yeah hello I wanna put it out there so
we can tackle this issue instead of just
being silent about it that's my main
objective
we just woke up 11 one of the brothers
organized the translated for us
barking message me in the morning and he
said that his kind of flopped so it's
not going to be coming so right now
we're in a bit of a dilemma because the
people here they don't speak English and
they're just being just French so we
need to find the translator otherwise
McCann we just can't do anything kind of
nothing here so what we're gonna do is
were in contact with a couple of people
just waiting for them to give us updates
what's going to happen initially we'll
trying to get I translated Chava
you know a desperate situation to do
this but I surely see what I lost once
as what planned for us we're gonna hit
stains right now
[Music]
[Music]
firstly canoe canoe can you ask him what
what does he know about what happened I
heard this that they published the
photos and videos the girl and it was
photoshopped and it's made her look in
an appropriate situation and then people
start talking and start bullying her in
social networks in her neighborhood a
neighborhood and the streets and then
the girl she got really annoyed and she
was so desperate to the point that she
committed suicide I heard about the
story from people from equals of what
happened to her but I do not know the
reality what I heard is she had a sexual
relationship with her boyfriend
it seems that she so she got afraid of
her brother she got scared and what so
she fled
when he came over she was clearly that's
gonna happy through and she just killed
herself she could be heard the story
saying that she had a sexual
relationship with her boyfriend video
and that was published online and it
ended up in the hands of her family so
she was so desperate and she took the
decision to end her life and say well
what I heard is that she didn't want to
kill herself she just wanted to hurt
herself and not kill herself
the she not does he know that the video
wasn't of her it wasn't her
does he know McKenith he has video and
it's mechanics he is some people saying
it was her some people say but I
personally saw cyclones on Facebook and
I'm sure it was her but we found out
that it's not her me personally I didn't
see the video so I cannot tell you if it
was heard in the video or not I heard
from friends and from the Bell from
people here in the neighborhood as I
told you I personally think it doesn't
matter if it was in the video do you
know that basically that video was a
slander like it wasn't her on the video
okay but but how is this how how is can
you ask him how is he so sure that it
was her Facebook account or just guide
her boyfriend okay okay okay let's let's
let's tell him that what we have been
told by the police and journalists that
the video is not of her who does he
think is responsible for her death
I think that the flourishes will publish
the video of the photo in the first
place he's the one to blame
first of all poles people that spoke
about her all the people that bullied
her they are partners in this kindest
crime you know why Hamid peace be upon
him has recommended us true or false we
don't have to interfere people be big
business people life so I disagree with
that
in my opinion I seen the people have
criticized her the people need people
who just judge and she's a bad person
she's a bad girl even her closest
friends were supposed to support her and
stand by her side and of course the
pressure on her in a way that she felt
scared to speak to them and she ended up
by killing herself anyone in our age
will feel scared in her situation no one
can judge what would you say the
community should have done instead of
maybe it's the sound of bullying yeah
they should have stayed quiet about it
and have respect for her and having a
family and for them too
because it's the same code is it because
they're not like nobody knows
hundred-percent what happened
ya know yeah as far as I know nobody
knows Anderson
like what would you advise me to give to
the people watching out there you know
if they don't they three weeks ago a
fourteen-year-old Muslim girl called I
saw was accused of a lie in a slander a
video went viral and this land was made
against her but she committed zina and
the person in the video was her and the
community and her and the people in the
social media turned against her and
pushed her so far that she had no choice
but to commit suicide as a way out my
promise and sisters I want to talk to
you guys about another I shot and this
actually is very dear to us it's the
mother of the believers
I should add the other one I shall run
our mother was slandered against when
she was traveling with the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him on a journey
in a desert
unfortunately I shall kill her and was
separated by the caravan and she was
lost and
hoggle of allah a Sahaba by the name of
swan even wattle was going past and he
saw a shadow and Allah and he did not
speak anything except to bring his camel
near the camel down so I shouldn't allow
and can jump on the camel and so he can
catch up with a caravan when they
arrived at their destination the leader
of the hypocrites
abdullah even obey saw this started a
slander a lie against the mother of the
believers these movements and these
llamas went on for a whole month and
when i shall add yellow hand heard this
she was so distressed she said that she
was she would cry every night she would
cry as she was in distress and she
didn't know what to do just as a
situation where many of the sisters
would be with the slander now when the
prophet mohammed peace be upon him one
day says you know what he approaches I
shall hardly allow and and says look I
have heard what they've been saying
indeed if it says slander Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala will clarify this matter and
clean your name and clear your name but
indeed if you did commit this sin Allah
is oft-forgiving most-merciful just
repent now these words of the Prophet
peace be upon him
her--her because it made her feel like
he stood out sir so she was really
distraught and this carried on and
subhanallah brothers and sisters Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala indeed his most trust
he sent down revelation in surah noor
verse 11 he says and the slander was
made against you I shall amongst a gang
among you and indeed do not think that
this land is bad for you indeed it is
good for you those who made this land
are under their judgment their sins will
be put forth to them and the ones who
play the bigger part indeed they will
suffer the consequences thereof and in
the following verses Alice once Allah
talks directly to those people who
slandered against Aishah bridle on and
said those amongst you why did they not
make an excuse why did they say you know
what no maybe it wasn't her any kind of
excuse made possible to clear her name
and when Alice wants Allah send these
verses down he directly was conveying
that message to the people who started
this London accusations and Allah says
in the Quran all believing men and women
why did you not make good excuses for
Aisha and not only a shock for anybody
that gets laundered why did you not been
good even if the video was out or
whatever it is why did you not say you
know what it's not her it can't be her
she wouldn't do that why did you not
make good excuses for her and all the
small said in the following verses why
did they not bring 4 witnesses indeed if
they are truthful and not only that and
Alice once Allah says indeed you did not
bring these witnesses you are a liar in
my eyes you are a liar so this is what
Allah so Allah is harshly addressing
those people who do the slander and make
every excuse to blame the individual and
following the verses Allah so Allah says
had it not been my Grace and my mercy in
this life and the Hereafter indeed a
severe punishment would have fall upon
you while you was talking and slandering
saying things that
have no knowledge of like it's something
small indeed Allah says for me what you
did was grave it was big in my sights
why did you not say when you heard
indeed it is not for me to talk about
it's got nothing to do with me and move
away Alice wants Alice says in the final
verses I warn you that indeed if your
true believers do not repeat the same
thing again with another individual now
brothers and sisters as we heard how
Alice once had a sit-down revelation to
protect the owner of isodyne yellow hand
and all the people those verses are not
only just for I should add Aloha and for
those people that gets landed as well
now brothers and sisters I just want to
share a quick story of who might even
cut up now the reason why I share this
story in brief is because how many of us
when we hear something we jump to
assumptions accusation that was tough
spreading rumors this rumor cost
somebody's life and I'm sure there's
thousands of sisters or brothers out
there being slandered against who might
have been caught up when he was the
amirul mumineen
a female came and she was pregnant and
people were saying that she has
committed zina and she came to marry me
cut off said Oh Ameer al-mumineen I am a
virgin
now imagine guys if you saw a pregnant
girl would you say she is a virgin no
you wouldn't
you will instantaneously know she
hundred percent committed zina this is
what the characteristics of a true
believer
I made a movement in the Omar even Qatar
gave the benefit of the doubt she came
and told the story and said indeed I am
a heavy sleeper when I sleep nothing
wakes me up she says one day when I woke
up I saw semen all over me and this is
scientifically proven that there is a
chance of the sperm entering and a
female being pregnant even when she's a
virgin she hasn't committed the act and
almighty bin khattab believe the woman
gave her the benefit of the doubt how
many of us if we heard this we would be
like she committed you know we would
janta accusations and all kinds of
madness
my brother sis's the reason why I share
the message of American Kitab is because
we was interviewing a brother came along
and I told him clearly that this was a
slander made against the system the
police and the journalists saying that
the video was not offer but he turned
around to me and said no I've watched
the video and it was offer and I was not
know firstly why he watching the video
secondly why can you make good
assumptions instead you're so point
trying to support your case and to prove
a point that it was her one line if you
are a true believer you would make every
single excuse to protect the name and
the owner of any system that Miss Sandoz
be made against and I hundred percent
oldest I'm sorry but I do not believe in
that even if he saw what he saw I don't
believe it the police and the
journalists say that it wasn't her and
what lie I put 100% in that and I assume
the best and I believe that our sister
Aisha wasn't the one in the video 100%
now I want to finish off with addressing
four people number one my dear sister if
a slander is made against you what Allah
you do not ever despair the mercy of
your Lord no matter what you go through
just as Oliphant Allah said in surah
noor verse 11 indeed those assumptions
and those negative assumptions that I
made against you is good for you unless
one tell us reassuring you let them
smother against you sister let them
stand there against you indeed on the
day of judgment you will grab every
single one of their good deeds for
yourself and that might be a ticket for
you to enter Jannah and it might even
cause them to enter the Hellfire so my
dear sister as a brother I'm telling you
while I do not everything that suicide
is an option
suicide is not an option my dear sister
I'd be strong if you need to talk I'm
here my team is er their assistance how
they would that would love to help you
but Allah I asked for the sake of Allah
do not ever think about suicide My dear
sister Allah do not ever think about
that
shame on those who put you in this
situation where you see nothing but
there's an optional shame on them now
the second person that I want to address
is my dear sister if you have committed
this act if
these videos or whatever is being
circulated around you my dear sister I
know you're gonna go through tough times
but what lie Allah says in the Quran
indeed my servants who have transgressed
against themselves do you not ever
display the mercy of your Lord o Allah
he my sister we are not perfect none of
us are perfect we all fall for a sin no
matter what sin you do repent turn to
your Lord but wallah don't go through
them don't ever see suicided an option
do not ever feel my dear sister that you
I will never forgive you what life is
from Shaytan thirdly if you are a family
member if you are a brother or an uncle
or a father that has heard this story or
heard this land or heard this slander or
Lackey there is a big role that you play
in this matter there is a big role that
you play in this matter if you have
heard such a thing if you have heard
such a thing if there is no evidence my
dear brother do not ever doubt your
sister against those who slander indeed
the stander is a big sin don't believe
them don't do something that you have no
knowledge of that
Alice want allah says in the quran in
surah noor don't talk about a matter
that you have no knowledge of think the
best assume the best of your sister
do not ever believe their story and then
turn to your sister or your daughter or
whoever it may be and start beating them
and starts cursing them and making their
life hell you don't know you do not know
if it is phew now let's assume that I
did happen it was her yeah Ikey is it
the right thing to do say beat her kick
her out
My dear Bravo maybe you are to blame
maybe as much as she made a mistake you
are to blame for not helping her through
not talking to her for not show another
love that she has to go outside and find
a love with somebody else
maybe you as a parent
you are to blame for not taking care of
your daughter for not showing of the
love everybody easily points to blame at
the female but do you ever think what
have I done have I done the right thing
have I shown enough love to my daughter
have I shown enough love to my sister
have I protected her have I tried to
educate her No then you are to blame as
much as she may be for falling for the
sin or alva ignorance now last but not
least those who spread slander while lie
I fear the punishment for you if you do
not repent on the day of judgement all
you people in France and wherever it may
be in the world that you share this
video you laugh about it you your hands
are stained in blood how will you answer
Allah on the day of judgment when a
slander or even if the story was true
you help that story reach more and more
people how do you sleep at night
wallah how do you sleep at night knowing
Allah sent down a revelation for those
who stand up for those who slander
against individuals and talk about
matters that you have no knowledge of
what Allah he for you even for you Anna
has mercy Allah has Rama repent and
Allison says in surah Noor I warn you to
not repeat the same acts don't go back
and commit the same Stunner with another
individual make as much excuses as
possible after looking into this matter
going there speaking to the public I
truly believe the biggest portion of the
blame is on the family the community and
those people who share this video and
slander against our sister and my dear
brothers and sisters I want your help
all I please this is all I need from you
I beg of you
we don't want to lose another life
another innocent sister to these slander
so please today we are going to hashtag
who killed Aisha and I want you to share
this video link with the hashtag all
over social media and I want you to
share this with every single youtubers
Facebook page Instagram whatever it may
be we want this message to reach the
thousands and our objective is number
one to clear her name and indeed it was
a stander made against her number two we
want to raise money to do static Acharya
for her be build to water wells and
twelve olive trees so indeed many people
didn't benefit benefit her in this life
so at least let's do a couple of things
for her in the hereafter brothers and
sisters
and this is about it from me may Allah
support Allah's mercy and blessings be
upon you all assalamu alayka what I
meant
[Music]
I said be a warrior Danna
and I all saw a gator sturdier what a
boasted no I would love he is funny
yes nos can follow mommy